[Music]
okay you lost your parents welcome home
you're my niece I'm gonna do everything
I can to make this place feel like home
just wish I could see them again
I'm not equipped to handle this I don't
even take care of my own plants
[Music]
this project at work do you want to see
yes
ever since I was little I dreamed of
this perfect toy that would protect a
kid from ever feeling lonely or sad this
is Megan Hi Megan I'm Katie
it's nice to meet you Katie do you want
to hang out
okay
[Music]
your goal is to protect Katie from harm
both physical and emotional is that a
doll model 3 generative Android Megan
for sure I can't believe you made this I
love it
[Music]
great job it's nice
it's honestly like she's part of the
family now there could be building
emotional connections that are too hard
to untangle she's the happiest she's
been since her parents died eat the
toppings Katie research shows if you
force a child to eat vegetables they'll
be less likely to choose those Foods as
adults is that so yes experts they can
turn off
I thought we were having a conversation
does she talk
make her say something stop
you should probably run
[Applause]
[Music]
she pushed Brandon onto the road I won't
let anything harm you
there you go turn off recalibrating
response model
[Music]
hey what's wrong with you don't worry
Katie
I won't let anything harm you
ever again
[Music]
foreign
[Music]